You take a drink with your friends and
somebody says,
yeah,
we should go skydiving tomorrow,
and you go,
yeah,
we'll go skydiving,
or yes,
so then that night you're laying in your
bed and you just keep.
You're terrified.
You keep imagining over and over again
jumping out of an airplane and you can't
figure out why you would do that and you
laying there and you have the worst
night's sleep of your life.
You wake up the next day and you go down
and you said where you were going to
meet and everybody's there,
so you get in a van and you don't know
that your friends had the same night
that you had because they're pretended
like they didn't.
They were like,
yeah man,
my uncle is a navy seal and you know
this is going to be great.
I'm looking forward to this.
And you're like,
oh my God.
Oh my God,
and your stomach is terrible.
You can't eat and everything,
but you don't want to be the only one
who doesn't jump out of this airplane.
So you get there and then you have the
safety brief and you're standing there.
And the guys will tell you what the
chute doesn't open.
What's going to happen is you're doing,
you want help with.
So you fly and you go up,
you go up,
you go up and you go up to 14,000
feet and you notice there's a.
A light is red and it's yellow and
green,
right?
So right now the light's red.
So then you start thinking,
at some point the light's going to go
green.
If you don't know what's going to
happen,
right?
And you wait and negotiate yellow and
the light goes green and somebody opens
the door.
And in that moment you realize you've
never been in a freaking airplane with
the door open.
And you go and the guy walks you up to
the end of the thing and you're standing
and your toes are on the edge and you're
looking out down to death.
And they say,
Oh,
I'm three.
And they say one,
two.
And he pushes you on to.
Because people grab on three and you go
and you fall out of the airplane.
And in one second you realize that it's
the most blissful experience of your
life.
Your flying right,
it doesn't feel like falling,
right?
It's like you actually are kind of held
a little bit by the wind and then you
start and you start falling.
You're falling and you.
There's zero fear.
You realize that the point of maximum
danger is the point of minimum fear.
It's bless,
bless,
and you're flying and you're doing that
and then 20 seconds,
25 seconds,
40 seconds,
and you have enough time to just kind of
like,
oh shit.
That's that building.
I,
I like that.
And the lesson for me was,
why were you scared in your bed the
night before?
Why did you.
What do you need that fear for bundling
you scared in your bed.
Sixteen hours before you jump.
Why are you scared in the car?
Why could you not enjoy breakfast with
what?
What?
What did you need to fear is fear of
what?
You're nowhere even near to the
airplane.
Everything up to the stepping out.
There's actually no reason to be scared.
It only just ruins your day,
your.
You don't have to jump,
and then in that moment,
all of a sudden where you should be
terrified is the most blissful
experience of your life,
and God placed the best things in life
on the other side of terror,
on the other side of your maximum fear,
all of the best things in life.